20-17 was a show devastating hurricanes
the deadliest mass shootings on record
Colin Kaepernick's still not having a
job the constant in ability of men with
power to not be rapey the trump
presidency hi Donald John Trump do
solemnly swear and it was an especially
tough year for journalism in the United
States none of this is fake news we can
put away the fake news charge once and
for all and you're not going to give you
a can you stay you are fake dude he does
this constantly again and again and
again and again
the term fake news surged during the
2016 election and was used to point out
the rise of fabricated stories and
websites we're talking about stories
like the Pope endorsing Donald Trump or
that Donald Trump was born in Pakistan
for the record he didn't he definitely
wasn't after his election president
Donald Trump flipped the script he
started using the term fake news to
describe mainstream news media like CNN
MSNBC ABC The New York Times The
Washington Post sure they get it wrong
now and then and they miss some of the
stories we covered here at aj+ but they
follow the basic procedures of
journalism
they're not fake news in 2017 the term
fake news pretty much became an unfunny
meme thrown at everything anyone
disagreed with
and while 2016 was called a year of fake
news 2017 has been the year of wealth a
crisis of legitimacy for journalism but
was it actually hey guys I'm Sunna this
is AJ plus and this Sunday we're gonna
take a crash course in some of the
biggest and most important investigative
stories that held the powerful
accountable in 2017
[Music]
so let's start off with the one-story
you definitely know Harvey Weinstein on
October 5th
Jodi Kanter and Megan Chui of the New
York Times reported that the Hollywood
mega producer had spent decades paying
off women who had accused him of sexual
misconduct
it was a huge scoop followed just days
after by another investigation by Ronan
Farrow for The New Yorker barrows
investigation went into detail on the
numerous accounts of sexual abuse both
harassment and assault that Weinstein
was accused of and the investigative
work done by these journalists had a
huge impact Weinstein's career came to
an end then there was a me-too campaign
very public conversations about sexual
harassment and assault and most
significantly the Weinstein story set
off a series of investigations and
allegations against other powerful
people many of whom are now jobless
another incredible investigation that
came towards the end of 2017 was the
uncounted journalists osmocon a ton ago
Paul spent 18 months looking at the
civilian cost of the us's war against
Isis in Iraq for their investigation
Condon Gopal went door-to-door at the
sights of a hundred and fifty airstrikes
in northern Iraq they found that the
actual rate of dead civilians since 2014
was 31 times higher than what was
officially reported this from an air
campaign that was supposedly according
to the United States the most precise in
history I spoke to Han about the New
York Times Magazine investigation asking
her why she decided to pursue this story
and why it was so important to tell we
decided to tell this story because we
were seeing vast discrepancies between
what was actually happening on the
ground and claims that were being made
about how precise and how accurate this
air war actually was this is a story
about accountability and transparency
and it's about this vast gap between
what the government says about how
that's going and the reality on the
ground
in addition to predators and possible
war crimes the world's rich Elise
weren't safe either
remember 2016's panama papers'
investigation about the offshore bank
accounts of some of the richest and most
powerful people in the world
well the international consortium of
journalists dropped another massive
investigation in late 2017 the paradise'
papers like its predecessor the Paradise
Papers focused on leaked documents
revealing that the offshore financial
habits of the rich and powerful maybe
weren't all that halal why was this
investigation such a big deal well it's
the fifth massive financial leak of its
kind over the course of four years and
while the point of offshore finance is
essentially to evade accountability
exposing who's hiding money and why
forces accountability in fact the Panama
papers of 2016 led to several worldwide
investigations high-profile resignations
arrests and political upheavals one of
2017 s most riveting reads was ginger
Thompson's how the u.s. triggered a
massacre in Mexico in 2011 convoys from
the Zetas drug cartel rolled into the
town of IND in northern Mexico the Zetas
cartel believing some of their own
members had betrayed them started
gathering their friends and families
they took them to a ranch killed them
and burned their bodies the
investigation by ProPublica and National
Geographic found that at the root of the
IND Massacre was the DEA prematurely
sharing information about informant with
a notably corrupt Mexican Police
Department a follow-up investigation by
Colegio D'Amico found that the death
toll was far from the official count of
28 and instead was closer to 300 when I
asked ginger Thompson why it was
important to cover the story this is
what she had to say I think the United
States sort of looks at what's going on
in Mexico as Mexico's problem in this
case we were able to show very clearly
the link between a DEA operation gone
wrong and dozens as many as hundreds of
lives many of them innocent lives
that were lost next is NPR's ongoing
investigation to the spread of black
lung across coal country one of
President Donald Trump's big campaign
promises was to bring back Kol jobs to
the Appalachian region you know in other
countries they love their call over here
we we haven't treated it with the
respect it deserves
but what's usually ignored when it comes
to the coal industry is its health cost
according to NPR's ongoing investigation
there are over 2,000 cases of advanced
black lung all diagnosed in 2010 black
lung by the way is this awful disease
that literally turns your lungs black
and essentially kills you slowly by
choking you to death over the course of
a lot of years and while it's entirely
preventable the coal industry has
repeatedly ignored taking the steps
necessary to combat it finally on our
list is Nicole Hannah Joneses the
resegregate of Jefferson County the new
york times magazine investigation looked
at how cities in the south specifically
in Alabama were resegregate Acuto Thalia
legal means cities in Jefferson County
were creating new school systems that
kept and are still keeping black
students out so there you have it some
of the best investigative work done by
journalists in the United States in 2017
not everyone's gonna love what our
stories show but our stories will be
fair they will be accurate they'll be
balanced we're already seeing
journalists help rebuild that trust and
a large part of that is doing great
investigative journalism and a lot of
that is showing your work but what will
it take for journalists to regain the
trust of a citizenry that's just become
too skeptical hey guys if you liked that
video don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and let us know in the
comments what were your favorite
investigative stories of 2017 mine the
crazy Washington Post investigation
about the woman who was making a false
accusation against Roy Moore and it
turned out that she was part of an
organization investigating the
Washington Post it was a weird story